did Muhammad perform miracles did he
demonstrate his Divine Authority by
bringing signs and wonders according to
the Quran no according to most Muslims
today yes why do so many Muslims believe
the exact opposite of what Allah says in
the Quran there are two main reasons
first although Islam is officially the
religion of submission to Allah in
reality it's the religion of submission
to shakes and imams and daag gists who
lie for a living so what Muslims hear
about Muhammad is often very different
from what the Quran says about Muhammad
second Muslims are familiar with stories
about Jesus and Moses performing
Miracles by Allah's leave and they
really really really want to believe
that Muhammad could do the same thing
even though the Quran says over and over
again that he couldn't so who's right
who says that Muhammad was just a Warner
who brought the Quran or the shakes and
imams and daag gandis to say that
Muhammad split the moon and shot water
out of his fingers and flew around on a
magic donkey let's read a few passages
from the Quran Surah 2: 118 to
119 and those who have no knowledge say
why does not a law speak to us or a sign
come to us even thus said those before
them the like of what they say their
hearts are all alike indeed we have made
the communications clear for a people
who are sure surely we have sent you
with the truth as a bearer of good news
and as a Warner and you shall not be
called upon to answer for the companions
of the flaming fire notice the
unbelievers are asking why Allah hasn't
given them a sign Allah's response is
that his Comm Communications are clear
and that Muhammad is a bearer of good
news and a Warner sah
6:37 and they say why has not a sign
been sent down to him from his Lord say
surely Allah is able to send down a sign
but most of them do not know why didn't
Allah send Muhammad with a miraculous
sign well Allah is able to send down a
sign but he decided not to Surah 10
verse 20 and they say why is not a sign
sent to him from his Lord say the Unseen
is only for Allah therefore wait surely
I too with you am of those who wait why
didn't Allah send a sign to Muhammad the
world may never know because the Unseen
is only for Allah so just keep waiting
Surah
11:2 then it may be that you Muhammad
will give up part of what is revealed to
you and your breast will become
straightened by it because they say why
has not a treasure been sent down upon
him or an angel come with him you are
only a Warner and Allah is custodian
over all things here Allah is worried
that Muhammad's feelings will be hurt
because he wasn't given any
Miracles Surah 13:7 and those who
disbelieve say why has not a sign been
sent down upon him from his Lord you are
only a Warner and there is a guide for
every people why didn't Allah send
Muhammad with a sign because Muhammad
was only a Warner sorah 13: 27 and those
who disbelieve say why is not a sign
sent down upon him by his Lord say
surely Allah makes him who will go
astray and guides to himself those who
turn to him why didn't Allah send
Muhammad with a sign because signs are
irrelevant Allah decides who's going to
believe and who's not going to believe
so who needs a sign Surah
17:59 and nothing could have hindered us
that we should send signs except that
the Ancients rejected them and we gave
to samud the she camel a manifest sign
but on her account they did Injustice
and we do not send signs but to make men
fear why didn't Allah send any
miraculous signs to show that Muhammad
has his stamp of approval because some
people in the past rejected Miracles so
Allah decided to stop sending them sorah
17: 88 to 94 say if men and Jin should
combined together to bring the like of
this Quran they could not bring the like
of it though some of them were aiders of
others and certainly we have explained
for men in this Quran every kind of
similitude but most men do not consent
to ought but denying and they say we
will by no means believe in you until
you cause a fountain to gush forth from
the earth for us or you should have a
garden of palms and grapes in the midst
of which you should cause rivers to flow
forth gushing out or you should cause
the heaven to come down upon us in
pieces as you think or bring Allah law
and the angels face to face with us or
you should have a house of gold or you
should Ascend into to heaven and we will
not believe in your ascending until you
bring down to us a book which we may
read say glory be to my Lord am I ought
but a mortal Apostle and nothing
prevented people from believing when the
guidance came to them except that they
said what has Allah raised up a mortal
to be an apostle so the unbelievers
declare they won't believe in Muhammad
until he shows them some sort of Miracle
Allah tells Muhammad to replace reply
guys I'm only a mortal
Apostle sah 29: 50 to 51 and they say
why are not signs sent down upon him
from his Lord say the signs are only
with Allah and I am only a plain Warner
is it not enough for them that we have
revealed to you the book which is
recited to them most surely there is
Mercy in this and a reminder for a
people who believe what's the question
why are not signs sent down upon him
from his Lord what's the response the
signs are only with Allah I am only a
plain Warner isn't it enough that Allah
sent the worst book in
history over and over and over like a
beating drum people asked Muhammad why
he couldn't perform
Miracles over and over and over like a
beating Drum in a drum battle the
response was that Muhammad was only a
Warner his miracle was the lovely Arabic
of the Quran now if Muhammad had been
performing Miracles all along as most
Muslims believe we would expect a very
different answer if muhammmad had been
performing Miracles all along then when
people asked why can't Muhammad perform
Miracles the response should have been
what are you talking about Muhammad
performed per Miracles all the time if
Muhammad had been performing Miracles
all along as most Muslims believe why
does the Quran repeatedly make excuses
instead of Simply listing Muhammad's
numerous
Miracles this is the point in the
discussion where our Muslim friends jump
in with two Quran verses that supposedly
claim Muhammad performed two Miracles
his night journey and splitting the moon
but watch what happens when we take a
closer look at the so-called miracles in
these verses we read about the night
journey in Surah 17 verse one glory be
to him who carried his servant By Night
from the holy mosque to the further
mosque the precincts of which we have
blessed that we might show him some of
our signs he is the all hearing the
allseeing Muslims interpret this in
light of later Muslim sources much later
Muslim sources
which insist that this verse is about
Muhammad flying from Mecca to Jerusalem
on a magic flying donkey Monster named
Barack but what does the verse actually
say anything about a magic flying donkey
monster no anything about
Jerusalem no anything about
Muhammad no the verse says that Allah
carried his
servant who the servant
here the only servant who's named is
Moses in the next verse let's read 171
again but in context glory be to him who
carried his servant By Night from the
holy mosque to the further mosque the
precincts of which we have blessed that
we might show him some of our signs he
is the all hearing the
allseeing and we gave Moses the book and
made it a guidance to the children of
Israel take not unto yourselves any
Guardian apart from me the seed of those
we bore with Noah he was a thankful
servant and we decreed for the children
of Israel in the book you shall do
corruption in the earth twice and you
shall Ascend exceeding high in context
Surah 17 verse one sounds like it's part
of a story about Moses and there are
Muslims who interpret it this way
Muhammad isn't even mentioned so Muslims
who want to believe that this is about
Muhammad's night Journey have to go
outside the Quran to later sources to
find out that this is about Muhammad not
about Moses sad that Allah couldn't
clarify what he meant in his perfectly
clear book but the main problem for
Muslims who want to believe that 171 is
about Muhammad performing a miracle is
that according to our earliest descript
itions of Muhammad's night Journey which
are still extremely late the night
Journey was a vision or a dream Muhammad
never left Mecca as we read in Ian asak
page
183 one of Abu bakr's family told me
that Aisha the prophet's wife used to
say the Apostle's body remained where it
was but God removed his Spirit by Night
yakub bin utba bin Al mugir bin Al akas
told me that muaah bin Abu sufyan when
he was asked about the apostles night
Journey said it was a true vision from
God what these two latter said does not
contradict what alhassan said seeing
that God himself said we made the vision
which we showed thee only for a test to
men nor does it contradict what God Said
in the story of Abraham when he said to
his son oh my son verily I saw in a
dream that I must sacrifice thee and he
acted accordingly thus as I see it
Revelation from God comes to the
prophets waking or
sleeping so Muhammad's body remained
where it was it was a true vision from
God Allah said we made the vision which
we showed thee only for a test to men
it's a quote from the Quran as I pointed
out Surah 7 :1 says absolutely nothing
about Muhammad in context it sounds like
part of a story about Moses but if verse
one is about Muhammad then Surah 17
verse 60 refers back to whatever
happened Allah declares and when we said
to you surely your lord encompasses men
and we did not make the vision which we
showed you but a trial for men and the
cursed tree in the Quran as well and we
caus them to fear but it only adds to
their great
inordinately insists that Muhammad
couldn't perform Miracles but what about
Muhammad splitting the moon Surah 54: 1
to3 the hour draws nigh and the Moon is
split aunder but if they see a sign they
turn aside and say magic continuous and
they call it a lie and follow their
lusts but every matter is settled so
where does this say Muhammad did
anything doesn't but this is another
instance where later Muslim sources
claim that Muhammad performed a miracle
these much later sources say that the
pagans challenged Muhammad to split the
moon Muhammad accepted the challenge and
split the moon right in front of the
pagans this should make us wonder why
the Quran is filled with verses about
pagans asking why Muhammad never came
with Miracles even though he supposedly
split the moon in front of them but
there's another problem here Muslims
can't even agree on what Surah 54:1 is
talking about the halim translation says
the hour draws near the Moon is split
but there's a note which reads one of
the signs of the day of judgment the
Arabic uses the past tense as if that
day were already here to help the reader
listener imagine how it will be some
traditional commentators hold the view
that this describes an actual event at
the time of the Prophet but it clearly
refers to the end of the world and the
Quran uses similar language about the
end of the world elsewhere so some
Muslims believe this has absolutely
nothing to do with Muhammad splitting
the moon it's about the day of judgment
here's the YF Ali
translation the hour of judgment is nigh
and the Moon is cleft
asunder and here's YF Ali's commentary
three explanations are given in the muat
and perhaps all three apply here one
that the moon once appeared cleft
asunder in the valley of Mecca within
sight of the Prophet his Companions and
some unbelievers two that the prophetic
past tense indicates the future the
cleaving assunder of the Moon being a
sign of the Judgment approaching and
three that the phrase is metaphorical
meaning that the matter has become clear
as the Moon that the first was noticed
by contemporaries including unbelievers
is clear from verse two the second is an
incident of the disruption of the solar
system at the new creation compare 758
to9 and the third might well be implied
as in eastern allegory based on the
other two YF Ali thinks all three
explanations May apply that seems silly
since these are very very different
interpretations so pick one he says that
the first explanation the moon splitting
in the sight of the mechans is clear
from verse two I don't think it's clear
at all verse two even in the yusf Ali
translation says but if they see a sign
they turn away and say this is but
transient magic notice this doesn't say
that the Muslims and polytheists of
Mecca saw a sign it says if they see a
sign they turn away to me it sounds like
this passage is condemning the
polytheists of Mecca for rejecting the
Quran it's saying even if the day of
judgment was approaching and they saw
the Moon split apart they would just
make excuses and call it magic because
that's what they do when the Quran is
recited to them in other words it's like
when Abraham said in the parable of the
rich man and Lazarus if they do not hear
Moses and the prophets neither will they
be convinced if someone should rise from
the dead it's saying nothing will
convince people who refuse to accept
evidence the funny part is that we can
reverse the critic ISM here if a Muslim
wants to believe that Muhammad performed
Miracles and he clings to stories from
more than a century after Muhammad's
death Because he believes his favorite
dawa guy more than he believes what
Allah says in the
Quran is there anything we can say to
convince him that Surah 17 isn't talking
about Muhammad flying around on a magic
donkey
monster is there anything we can say to
convince him that Surah 54 isn't talking
about Muhammad splitting the moon in
front of the polytheists of
Mecca if Allah says over and over and
over in the Quran that Muhammad was only
a Warner and that his only sign was the
Quran and a Muslim rejects the clear
statements of Allah is that Muslim going
to listen to us of course not the
clearest statements in the Quran plainly
state that Muhammad couldn't perform
Miracles Muslims ignore all of these
verses and go to two extremely confusing
verses verses that don't even mention
Muhammad verses that are open to
multiple interpretations and they try to
convince us that Muhammad performed
Miracles even though they're
contradicting what Allah says in the
Quran why do Muslims do this it's for
the same reason Muslims long after the
Quran made up stories about Muhammad
performing Miracles and tried to force
them into the Quran we see the reason
for making up stories in the Quran
itself when Muhammad claimed to be a
prophet people challenged him to perform
Miracles couldn't so he made excuses but
the fact that these excuses show up
again and again in the Quran is evidence
that this was extremely embarrassing to
muhammmad and his
followers long after his death Muslims
started coming up with Miracle stories
turns out it was easier to make up
stories about miracles than to explain
why Muhammad couldn't perform
Miracles Muslims today are free to
continue this charade but it's just
silly to think that we're going to agree
with them when their earliest and most
authoritative Source the Quran says the
opposite of what they
believe the end of the day our Muslim
friends are just jealous they want
Muhammad to be more like
Jesus but Muhammad wasn't like Jesus
if they want someone like Jesus there's
no need to lie about Muhammad to make
him sound more
miraculous just believe in Jesus
[Music]